>>Narrator: Few parents can keep pace
with the rapid evolution
of digital technology.
Many don't have a handle on what
their kids are doing on the internet
and fear of the unknown
leads some to back away,
while others set strict
limits on their children.
Common Sense Media is a
nonprofit organization
that offers parents information
and practical advice on how
to support the digital generation.
>>When we started, it was
all about media consumption,
because we knew media
had a huge impact
on the way kids were being raised.
But then, as the world changed and
media became interactive and digital,
we've shifted to expand common sense
advice to how to behave online,
and what are the implications?
And how to be responsible and
get the most out of digital life.
The first thing I say to any parent
who's worried about digital life is,
"Hey, this digital
life, it's a good thing.
It's gonna help your kids
create, meet people, explore,
compose, express themselves.
They have more powerful
tools than they've ever had
in any generation in history.
So calm down.
This is a good thing."
But the next thing I say to them is,
"You're still in the parenting
business, and that means you have
to extend your parenting
skills into the digital world,
which means you've
gotta teach kids how
to be responsible,
how to behave kindly."
The golden rule exists in cyberspace.
You have to help kids protect
themselves so they don't over share,
since that will last forever
and get sent around to vast,
invisible audiences, but
to use some common sense
and to give them some
basic touchstones about how
to keep their kids safe and
smart and responsible online.
If a parent knows absolutely nothing,
my advice is to have their kid
show them what their life is.
Have them go onto a
social networking page.
Have them download a song.
Have them create a blog, upload a
picture, send an email with a picture
or a moving image to a
grandparent or someone far away,
so that they can have a
sense of the potential
of what's good about this world.
I mean, all of a sudden,
they can send to a relative
in another country a video
of someone's birthday party.
They can Skype somebody
and speak face to face.
You can explain these things to
parents, but the lived experience
of really getting involved
with it drives it home.
There's an added benefit
which is, kids feel then
that their parents are
embracing this world.
They're not prohibiting it.
They're not trying to tamp it down.
Because this is their world.
It's digital life to us,
but to them, it's just life.
So we really have to embrace it, and
that's whether you know a little bit
about it, a lot about
it or nothing at all.
The big time suck is really turning
out to be the cell phone with kids,
these endless text messages and the
endless connectivity to other people.
And that's a tough one to battle,
'cause you can either take the cell
phone away or not, and that turns
out to be a fruitless
enterprise, very quickly.
But you can help the
child really understand
that it is an option not to answer.
It is an option to turn it off.
It is an option to go to a movie
and enjoy the movie and be here now.
That's a sophisticated
argument to make
with a teenager whose entire
wiring is about being connected
to their friends at that age.
Some of it will pass, and parents
have to realize that the task
of a teenager, for instance, is
to be connected and to figure
out their identity in a social world.
Now they've got this extra tether
that connects them
at any point in time.
Hard to balance that when
that's really what they're wired
to be doing.
It's a tough one.
It starts with parents modeling
good balance themselves.
When it comes to limiting
media, and digital media,
it really depends on
the kind of media.
For instance, a lot of kids
are really addicted to World
of Warcraft, or online gaming.
You've gotta provide alternatives
when that is really becoming the
dominant part of their lives.
And you gotta encourage
them to do other things,
provide other opportunities.
The cell phone's a tougher one.
We have some hard and fast rules.
Many parents do.
The cell phone goes off at
night, that it doesn't go
to the dinner table, that
it's never used in classrooms.
But if you check your
cell phone bill,
you'll see that the cell
phone's being used and indeed,
there was one city that
just came out that showed
that parents text their kids during
school, and I've done that myself.
So, you know, that it really starts
with the values of the family.
Am I going to embrace technology
but also discuss its limits
in its proper time and space?
Yes. Are kids gonna listen to it?
Yes and no, but even when they
look like they're not listening,
they hear you, and it
shows up later in life.
Ultimately, our job as
parents is to empower our kids,
to teach them to protect
themselves and to teach them
to be responsible citizens
of the world.
So at a certain point, you have
to, as a parent, instill the values
that you have about being a good
digital citizen or human being.
And then encourage them
to independently use them.
So you can try and police, and
indeed, kids learn from mistakes.
So if you check a browser
history, like I did with my son,
and see three porn sites--
he's a fourteen year old.
It's age appropriate-- but I had to
have a discussion with him about,
"Hey, there's some
nasty things out there."
And I'm realistic.
I know at fourteen, I cannot
police where he's going,
but I can get in the discussion
and I can put my two cents in,
and I can give my values
and my wisdom,
because parents are still parents
and kids still need our wisdom.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org